faire son épicerie en ligne ne nous
éloigne pas des pièges du marketing je
vous offre quelques astuces pour les
éviter ou à tout le moins les voir venir
lorsqu'ils se dressent devant vous
[Musique]
ne tombez pas dans les pièges du
marketing
pour vous aider l'épicerie lève le voile
sur certaines techniques utilisées par
l'industrie pour vous vendre ses
produits aujourd'hui la publicité dans
l'univers numérique
vous le savez les plateformes d'épicerie
en ligne sont de plus en plus populaires
mais ce que vous ne savez peut-être pas
c'est qu'on essaie souvent d'orienter
vos achats la publicité se fait subtile
sachez quand vous faites votre épicerie
en ligne que un peu sur le même principe
du circuit bien étudié qu'on a
physiquement à l'épicerie il y a un peu
un circuit aussi en ligne même si on ne
le voit pas ou même si on est dans un
environnement virtuel par exemple
l'ordre dans lequel les produits
apparaissent quand vous faites une
recherche sur une catégorie générale cet
ordre là est pas laissé au hasard les
produits les plus vendus apparaissent de
façon générale les premiers et où ceux
qui ont payé pour avoir une place dans
les premières pages parce que on sait
que recherche d'épicerie en ligne comme
recherche de n'importe quel sujet en
ligne rarement on va se rendre jusqu'au
bout des pages sur une catégorie alors
les entreprises peuvent payer pour avoir
une position privilégiée
vignette par ici bandeau par là produit
exclusifs à télépicerie toutes les
techniques sont bonnes pour attirer
votre attention
vous allez aussi voir apparaître lorsque
vous sélectionnez ou un produit sur
certaines plateformes des suggestions
soit d'aliments complémentaires ou de
concurrence selon les stratégies des
plateformes donc si j'achète du steak
haché fort probablement qu'on va me
proposer du blédard des patates pour
être sûr de bien compliqué avec la
recette qui vient avec d'ailleurs et ça
c'est une fonction sur les sites des
épiceries qui fonctionnent très bien qui
est très populaire surtout quand on peut
choisir une recette cocher les
ingrédients qui nous manquent et que ça
s'ajoute directement à notre panier ce
qui est super allez faire un tour dans
votre panier après parce que les
algorithmes vont avoir choisi quelle
marque de pommes de terre ou de maïs
sans grains ou en crème on va mettre
dans le panier mais c'est pas
nécessairement ce que vous auriez choisi
donc idéalement quand on fait son
épicerie en ligne il faut être aussi
stratégique que lorsqu'on est en magasin
avoir une liste savoir ce dont on a
besoin et oui observer se laisser tenter
mais judicieusement
si auparavant c'était facile de
reconnaître une publicité dans les
journaux ou à la télé aujourd'hui c'est
plus complexe de le faire dans l'univers
numérique les médias sociaux sont
devenus une stratégie de publicité
privilégié par beaucoup d'entreprises en
agroalimentaire notamment des plus
petites entreprises parce que c'est
beaucoup moins cher d'acheter de la
publicité sur Facebook ou sur Instagram
que celui de se payer un espace 30
secondes
juste avant le Téléjournal par exemple
c'est maintenant une tactique
publicitaire courante de voir des
influenceurs accepter d'être payées pour
parler d'un produit faut savoir que
toute personne en fait qui est payée
pour parler d'un produit doit le
déclarer donc tout influenceur qui est
le moindrement sérieux va avoir une
mention sur son blog au début ou à la
fin d'un vidéo pour dire parfois comment
ça ne veut pas dire que parce qu'ils ont
été payés par l'entreprise que ce qu'il
nous présente n'est pas objectif ça
reste que c'est eux qui décident du
message le message ne vient pas
directement de l'entreprise reste que
s'ils ont accepté d'en parler évidemment
il y a un certain biais parce qu'ils
apprécient le produit comme tel donc
même règle que pour n'importe quelle
publicité même si la personne qui vous
en parle et quelqu'un que vous aimez
beaucoup c'est pas parce que c'est dans
ses goûts et dans ses besoins c'est
nécessairement dans les vôtres
ça vous est déjà arrivé de faire une
recherche web sur la pizza et ensuite de
voir des publicités pizza à paraître un
peu partout c'est parce vous laissez
constamment des traces sur le web on dit
souvent que c'est le produit c'est nous
et non celui qu'on achète alors oui
absolument légère du web en fait une
grande part de leur chiffre d'affaires
et générée par la vente de ces
données-là à des entreprises de tous les
secteurs et notamment alimentaire
sachez que tout ce que vous faites sur
le web partout où vous naviguez vous
laissez des traces partout ces
informations-là sont corrigées par les
géants du Web et ils sont capables de
dresser un portrait
très très précis de l'ensemble de vos
habitudes et non pas juste alimentaire
si vous voulez pas vous faire un chalet
et laisser le moins de traces possible
évidemment on vide les mémoire caches on
fait attention où est-ce qu'on avait
mais quand vous voyez une publicité qui
est intéressante pour un produit
quelconque ce que je vous suggère c'est
que plutôt que de cliquer sur la
publicité ouvrez une nouvelle fenêtre et
aller directement sur le site du
fabricant pour en apprendre plus sur le
produit voir si ça vaut la peine et là
si oui vous cliquez sur la pub pour
bénéficier de la promo 6 promo il y a
mais à ce moment-là vous évitez de
continuer de laisser des multiples
traces et de
d'engraisser
ces fameux géants du web très judicieux
merci
[Musique]